on prime crime as i come out i guess
he's taking his step
okay taking a step taking his steps
towards me
a mild argument suddenly takes a violent
turn
i need a force multiplier because i
don't know what's going on but who's
responsible
when someone ends up dead the
decision-making process for a jury is
extremely difficult one
particularly in this case
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases we talk a
lot on the show about self-defense but
there's
one story in particular that really asks
the question
when can you use deadly force
july 19 2018 clearwater florida
what you're seeing is the surveillance
footage of a parking lot outside of a
convenience store
as you'll notice a car pulls up brittany
jacobs her boyfriend 28 year old marquis
mcglockton
and their three children are in the car
jacobs illegally parks in a handicapped
spot
while mcglockton goes into the store
when a confrontation starts
what goes through a lot of people's
minds depends on the confrontation
itself
less than a minute later then 47 year
old michael draka pulls into the lot
and then immediately begins arguing with
jacobs over where she parked
for the most part confrontations start
verbally
and that's a problem because when a
verbal confrontation is happening
normally what's going on inside
someone's brain is they're thinking
about what their answer is going to be
they're not listening to what the other
person has to say
so that leads to further and further
misunderstanding
and the more misunderstanding that
happens the more likely something
physical is going to happen he's the one
who parked illegally himself to complain
about someone else
parked illegally and then engaged in a
war of words
where bystanders took notice and stopped
and watched because it got so heated
mcglockton is alerted of the argument
outside and leaves the store
one of the things that fear as a primary
emotion what it can do is that
it can spark anger so
he might have feared that his girlfriend
was in trouble
but his emotional response wasn't one of
fear
it's one of action it's one of anger
it's one of adrenaline coursing through
his system
suddenly mcglockton pushes draken to the
ground draco responds
by quickly taking out a gun and firing
at mcglockton
he did have a concealed weapons permit
and so if he believed his life was
threatened
yeah he would be allowed to pull out the
gun
in that situation
mcglockton makes his way back into the
store and jacobs desperately tries to
stop the bleeding
but it's no use marquis mcglockton
later dies at the hospital now it's a
question of whether this was
self-defense
which is particularly interesting
considering florida
is a stand-your-ground state stand your
ground in florida
allows people to use deadly force
without having
to retreat from a dangerous situation if
they
reasonably believe that their lives are
threatened
the original intent was just to codify
the castle doctrine in the law
because there was a jury instruction and
some concern
that made it seem like we had a duty to
retreat that if someone broke into your
home
and threaten you you would have to
retreat before you can use deadly force
in response
so in response to those concerns
the legislature passed stand your ground
after the shooting draco waits for
police to arrive
is brought into an interrogation room
and voluntarily agrees to speak to
police
without a lawyer we're gonna take them
off you're gonna be cool oh gosh
yeah okay i don't know you i don't know
i know what's going on i know you have
my absolute words do you understand that
you have the right to remain silent
i'm going to need a verbal response if
you will okay do you understand anything
you say
can and will be used against you in the
court of law yes
thank you for being very professional he
was cooperative he didn't run he didn't
flee he gave them
a gun the reason why draco didn't run
away is because in his mind he believed
he was acting properly
in his mind he still believes he is a
pseudo police officer
i did exactly what i thought i was
supposed to be doing at that time
considering what was happening
let's get into that first why did draco
approach jacob's car
and why was he so upset at the parking
spot
every day there's somebody pulled in
any gap spot there just waiting on
somebody
because i have a pet peeve about it i
said it's not very polite to park here
when there's other people who need to
use this she says is it affecting you
directly i said if my mother i'm all
rolls in yes it will be
not only is draco's mother-in-law
handicapped but so was a deceased
ex-girlfriend of his them needing these
handicapped spots and then he sees other
people just taking advantage of these
handicap spots
they build over time this fantasy of him
becoming a
civic enforcer right a code enforcement
vigilante there's actually other like
empty parking spaces that are probably
closer and have better access to the
front door
that's the only one that has access to
that ramp in
in this particular situation though
if somebody can park right next to the
ramp walk around to it
doesn't really matter all that much i'm
not sure where this is
uh yes yes i think it is
yeah he believes himself to be the only
one that can set
all of these wrong things right whenever
he sees this one thing happens he feels
compelled
then to interact to engage and to
confront wouldn't it be best you think
to call law enforcement say hey
there's somebody illegally parked it's
not going to help
she'll leave okay well she may not
always do
in self-defense you have to ask who was
the aggressor
draca for starting the verbal
confrontation or mcglockton
for making it physical he was not the
initial aggressor didn't threaten her
he didn't put his hands on her he didn't
touch her he simply asked her a few
questions
he did nothing aggressively physically
or even
verbally he simply asked a few questions
it escalated to verbal argument
and then came the blind-sided push the
victim came out of the convenience store
and violently pushed the defendant to
the ground
but it was a defendant who then
escalated it further by
pulling out a weapon it would also be
determined that mcglockton
had ecstasy in his system he takes this
drug
it's stopping him from making more
rational decisions
had he not been on it maybe he doesn't
end up pushing draca
coming up did mcglockton pose a
legitimate threat to draco
i have no clue what he started and what
his endgame was
[Music]
i need a force multiplier because i
don't know what's going on what do you
mean a force multiplier
what exactly what you know what a force
multiplier no sir i don't
after a verbal confrontation over a
parking spot turned physical
michael draka took out a handgun and
shot marquis mcglockton to death
now being questioned by florida police
draco believes he was within his rights
to use deadly force
and has even cited the state's stand
your ground law
i shoot to save my own ass and that's
that the question though
is did draco reasonably perceive a
threat to his life
let's go back to the argument he had
with mcglockton's girlfriend brittany
jacobs
over parking in a handicapped spot the
thing i remember her saying
is do i have to get my man and i said
well what's that mean are we going to
fight
okay and well i guess so
was her answer standing like this
talking to her
i was hit from right here so he shoved
you pretty good
no he for what it felt like is he come
running at me
okay he was blindsided the fact that he
was knocked down
with excessive force and that as he was
on the ground
he watched the victim hovering over him
along with
his girlfriend and felt that he needed
to use excessive force at that time
if all you had just been blindsided with
no idea who was attacking
you would your firearm be out next move
you made
probably so what did you think he was
going to do thinking he's going to
finish what the hell he just started the
state downplayed the fact that he hurt
his arm
and if you look at his post arrest
interview he had it in a sling i'm
detective upton
left hand left hand okay stand your
ground
you can meet force with force but it
doesn't mean you get to
shoot someone who pushes you to the
ground the other person was unarmed
it happened so fast and that was that
did he say anything dude
negative not a word okay did you say
anything to him
no like back up no
so he made no threats that he was going
to come finish his
it was job assumption definitely okay so
you just assumed he was going to come do
that
any smart person would i never said a
word when he dumped me either
right now here's where things become
very important
listen closely to what draca says
mcglockton did
when he was on the ground i start
drawing my weapon
as i start leveling off my weapon he
makes his next step towards me how many
steps did he make
just one step okay but is that true did
mcglockton
actually move towards draco the
videotape
may say otherwise the victim had taken a
step or two backwards
the defendant's best argument is that he
was blindsided by a violent push
and so then he reacted but the problem
is is that
it wasn't just instinctual he had time
to see the victim
stop and take a couple steps away and
then shot him anyways
okay what happens if i told you that i
looked at the video and in no time and
point does he
come running up towards you he actually
takes a step back
i would disagree the way the law is
applied and the way we argued
it's not so much how the general public
views that moment
in time it's how he perceived that
moment in time did you have time to
really look at him and tell that he was
coming towards you the feet said he was
coming towards me and so did the hips
i think draco believed every single
thing that he was saying
remember when something happens that we
are unexpecting
time moves differently our perception
and everything that's going on
looks different so he probably did
believe that mcglockton was coming
forward
when mclaughton was actually turning
away he probably did believe
that there was no way to escape did you
make the decision
to shoot when you pulled the gun out or
was that afterwards negative decision i
made as soon as he moved
okay did you remember having time to
think and process the other time to sink
but you know that gun was out that the
twitch goes
that's it up next draka's past
sheds a whole new light on this shooting
stay with us
[Music]
i've never been in that situation ever i
thought kicks were coming
after shooting and killing marquis
mcglockton in a florida parking lot
michael draco tells police he thought
his life was in danger when mcglockton
shoved him after a fight over a
handicapped space
his interrogation revealed a lot about
him including when he was finally told
what happened to mcglockton
just to let you know the gentleman you
shot is deceased
thank you for telling me nobody else
would give me work on that
his interview seemed cold and calculated
didn't seem like he had any real empathy
for the victim in the case obviously he
didn't even react
to the death of the victim he felt
remorse from the day from day one from
the day i met him but he stood by the
fact that did nothing wrong his
explanation to us
about the whole interview with law
enforcement was that he was still
recovering from the shock of the event
i think he was grateful to know what the
condition and i think he asked
that's just how he is very very stoic
but was draco just protecting himself
that day
or looking for a fight i'm not after
being a justice kind of guy but when i
just say something to a person about
being parked there
i don't expect it to go where it went
draka though has a documented history of
road rage
and allegedly pulling a gun on people
that includes getting into an argument
with another man
over a parking space in the same lot as
the mcglockton shooting
so this guy is an aggressor he's an
instigator in his mind
he is a pseudo police officer
a vigilante who's out to make sure
people park
in the right spaces there was no use of
any guns
it's undisputed he took out a camera and
photographed
that that individual's parking in the
hand again submitted it to the
individual's
um uh boss but no use of guns no use of
press
there's again a hot head in my
definition without excusing or
minimizing what happened
is someone who confronts you each and
every instance with a gun
looking for a fight looking for a reason
to shoot you it never goes through your
mind that when you're going up and
talking to these people and informing
them of of
them being part of your handicap spot
that they might not take that right
it might go sideways a little bit well
sure
but that's why i take precautions as
well like what kind of precautions
oh i'm a very careful person and i have
a permit
having a gun and a stand your ground law
do two
different things having the gun
absolutely makes someone feel
invincible the law does something much
much
worse the law makes people believe that
they will be
justified in pulling their weapon and
escalating a confrontation to the point
where someone could actually die
in a surprising move the sheriff's
office didn't initially arrest draco
we're
conducting a thorough investigation this
investigation is going to be ongoing
okay we're not done with the
investigation there's a lot
to this to place all the parts together
when it comes to
stand your ground type cases there is a
hesitancy
to start making an arrest right away
because you need to investigate
all the circumstances around that
shooting
plus in this case the sheriff indicated
he thought
the defendant was within his rights to
shoot based on stand your ground
when the case was handed over to state
prosecutors though draco was ultimately
charged with manslaughter not first
degree murder clearly because it was not
a premeditated murder
and as far as whether it's second-degree
murder that usually involves
ill will none of that seems to apply
here this was a guy who was pushed down
pretty violently
and then reacted and shot dead the
victim and so really
is a manslaughter case rather than a
murder case
draca's attorneys had the option of
first arguing at a hearing
that their client was immune from
prosecution under the stand your ground
law
but we did not argue stand your ground
we did not file any pretrial motions we
didn't
argue for immunity based on stand your
ground
standard ground does not give you the
right to escalate
a fist fight into a gunfight
you can't just start shooting unarmed
people especially those who are trying
to
escalate the situation by taking a
couple steps back and that's why
the defense lawyers decided not to
pursue stand your ground and instead
just make it a
regular self-defense case when we return
draco goes to trial
and now has to convince a jury that he
acted in self-defense
will it work the decision-making process
for a jury is extremely difficult one
particularly in this case
they have to weigh whether or not draco
truly feared for his safety
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty
guilty think again judge caprio rules
with common sense
i was having contractions i was rushing
to the hospital inspector quinn what
does justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
welcome to prime crime tonight another
day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law and crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this is law and
crime
[Music]
as i come out i guess he's taking his
step okay
taking a step taking his steps towards
me
in 2019 michael draco finds himself on
trial in connection with the shooting
death of marquis mcglockton
what started as heated words over a
parking spot
soon turned violent mcglockton pushed
draco down
and draco fired his gun the government
argued the defendant committed
manslaughter
mr mclaughlin backs up as far as he can
go all the way to the car
he can't go back any further and watch
that video
he starts to turn away from the
confrontation
and he's shocked at that time
matter of fact the video speaks better
than i can
while draca's legal team ultimately
decided to not argue florida's stand
your ground law
they did have to convince this jury that
draca acted in self-defense
when using deadly force
we want you to look at it in real time
we don't want you to look at it
in slow motion because life doesn't
happen
the jury heard all different kinds of
evidence on use of force
pathology and even a past encounter
draca had over a handicapped spot
in that same lot but there was one
witness we
all waited to hear from the woman who
had the initial confrontation with draco
and who was right there during the
shooting mcglockton's girlfriend
brittany jacobs did the defendant shoot
marquise
yes was that after marquis went
backwards yes
i see marquis down there fighting for
his life so
i grabbed a t-shirt and i put it toward
his womb
and stopped the bleeding we said the
word
you know i retreated to the left and
marquis retreated
you never used the word retreat in any
of your statements to law enforcement
correct
i don't recall but i remember telling
him who was you know moving back
fair but you never said retreated
correct
i don't remember after over six
hours of deliberations the jury came
back
with their verdict to the charge of
manslaughter
we the jury find as follows as to the
defendant in this case
the defendant is guilty of manslaughter
as charged
if you start shooting you don't get to
do that under florida law to
shoot first and ask questions later he
brandished a weapon
and then the victim took a step or two
backwards
to de-escalate and then he was shot
and so in my mind the jury reached the
proper verdict
i think that came to the wrong decision
because of all the evidence that came in
such as
this prior uh incident involving the
same parking lot
where the facts were so dissimilar so i
think that
this image of a hothead absolutely came
into the jurors minds
i think that the trial should have been
focused simply on what happened
you know at the moment that he shot mr
block draco was sentenced to 20 years
behind bars
and his life inside hasn't gone so
smoothly
early on in during his incarceration he
was attacked
i don't know if they ever discovered if
it was racially motivated or if it was
just a random attack
uh he he's doing better now uh he has
had not any hasn't had any problems
since that attack he's in general
population he's awaiting the results of
the appeal uh
in good spirits and hopeful that he'll
get a new trial
at the time of this taping draca has
appealed his case
hoping for a new trial the attorney for
the state
personally attacked my co-counsel john
trevina you know mr trevina says well
you know a lot of people think this and
that that's not
evidence in this courtroom i don't care
what some nut wacko
right-wing guy thinks those are some of
just some of the few
examples that went on during the course
of the closing arguments that i think
will result in a new trial i think he's
going to lose on appeal
the defendant had a fair trial and the
reason why he was found guilty
is because he was guilty i think the
legacy of this case
is that stand your ground does not allow
you to
bring a gun to a shoving man sadly
though nothing's going to bring
the victim back to life his children
will grow up without a father
but hopefully the legacy of this case
will live on
to prevent future tragedies from
happening
the michael draka case is a fascinating
study in florida's stand your ground law
but it's also important because it
recognizes how quickly a minor argument
can turn into a senseless tragedy and i
think we should remember that
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on twitter
and instagram with the hashtag
primecrime
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
you